hello I'm Gao I'm done with the slow mo
guys this is circular
yeah I mean you may have seen some very
very stupid eating corn with the drill
this is slower guys so obviously we're
not the most intelligent people no well
they weren't gonna give it a go
rhett and Link did this so there must be
smart in somewhere okay I'll take it
so hopefully doesn't destroy my teeth
then you see happen so if they catch up
sure yeah hopefully your your hair won't
get pulled out your jaw that's off my
teeth will fall out yeah and it'll taste
nice let's hope for the best
alright you love em yeah don't let go
you can have that you get a perfect
great I'm like good rotisserie if ya
okay go fail
whatever flying you can see all the corn
goes into my mouth you see that
just all going in there
and everywhere
oh it's awful to look at it's so it's so
much more gross
it wasn't for the ketchup I'll be fine
he's never ending hold them absolutely
polished that's unbelievable
that might be the most efficient way so
we a corner shop yeah sure hmm
you missed a couple bits what take it
hmm not the most attractive video we've
ever made to tell you that I'm probably
vomiting I think yeah what a big thanks
to all a thousand of you who tweeted
that to us to do it it was a fantastic
idea I think you look tremendous
disgusting how do you store so much you
didn't know I had that in my mouth I was
just like yeah that was a different one
but we love it we love all kinds of uh
all kinds of slo-moes feel free to
follow us on Twitter
why sure if you want and subscribe to
the slow mo guys and maybe you'll see
more of this kind of thing in the future
but hopefully not oh good lord that was
gross Oh
you
don't catch up but absolutely not catch
it with that